very excited have this man here as part
of the new show on Fox the cool kids
series premiere tonight along with
Martin Mull Leslie Jordan Vicki Vicki
Lawrence good to see you David Alan
Grier to be here I'm a big fan I am just
just to let you know I'm not gonna go in
living color on you okay okay well I
mean I might do later on Hollywood
shuffle that led to everything the
Robert Townsend Hollywood shuffle that
led to everything someone just posted a
picture we did a sketch on there the
bold the black and the beautiful and I
forgot about that whole sketch I mean it
went on and on and on and on but I met I
met Robert Townsend when we did a
soldier's story the movie he told me all
about the wins
you know Keeney's I was his best friend
they were gonna form a movie company
homeboy pictures this is 1983 okay and I
was like okay cool so I go out to pilot
season come out here and he introduced
me to to Keenan and Damon who was about
150 pounds if he was no kidding oh yeah
tall skinny right and Damon always had
kids there was no time I met him that he
didn't have children
oh you're 15 it's my son right down
seven years old so I was like okay cool
so I met all of them from hanging out
that led to I'm gonna get you sucker
which Keenan did by the way with Jim
Brown right yes what was Jim Brown like
on that set Jim Brown never comes out of
character so this is my impression of
Jim Brown yeah doing a chicken joke
why'd the chicken cross the road why cuz
he wanted to give all kind of crazy
lines and he would just do it just like
he never ever tried to be funny he never
ever goosed the punchline he would just
do it and sit there staring at you even
when he's traveling on his own music his
theme music and the movie I'm just
telling you I'm just telling you and so
there was always a party and when you
looked he said like if you pushed his
button right
he could still square up and knock you
out I'm telling you David when the NFL
Network started it was one of the first
Hall of Famers that was willing to come
on or came in it was great and we were
gonna post tape him after a show for the
next day yeah but he showed up early
when we were in our live show yeah and
strolled out during a commercial break
on the set saying are we gonna do this
or not
Rich Eisen but I'll go get him
is there anything you want me to tell
him I was looking around like is
somebody going to we doing this or not
and I thought to myself like no you can
eyeball what you know I mean with his
eye he can still give you that eye and
you're like wow grandpa if you're within
reach
he's like a snapping alligator turtle
that just lies on the bottom of a lake
but if you come within reach of those
jaws he could still snatch you up oh man
david alan grier here on the Rich Eisen
show so we also share an institution of
higher learning do we not so say what
you're about to say with reverence sir
the University of Michigan I was there
Bo Schembechler mm-hmm
Woody Hayes you were there for the
10-year war yes I was even I went to one
oh hi Oh state game after that I
realized you could sell your tickets
because I mean people you know as a
student you gotta take it back yes she's
right so that was part of my financially
[Laughter]
well before stuff man please I said why
watch this on TV going to get it
yeah man when
Woody Hayes he snatched a kid and
punched him Harlan Huckabee he was he
went to my high school so all of that
stuff no I'm getting back in the day
that's back in the day yeah I covered
Bo's final season for the youth for the
Michigan daily
is he alive he is not sir I think he may
be still being well I mean his spirit is
alive somewhere well ain't Harbaugh
coaching inside our current coach bullet
I heard somebody told me how many
receivers have Michigan lost I heard a
bunch of people transferred well one of
one of their more talented young
receivers hurt his foot okay so I mean
yeah he hurt his foot no but we're you
know Michigan just coming off a big win
against Nebraska I mean really is that a
big a large final score yeah they have
to I have not given up on hardball and I
don't know what the recruiting stuff is
but he's got to do something do you
think he's on the line or well I don't
think he's on the line no I cannot but
the recruiting you know seems to get
better and better every year it's just
the you mean for Michigan or for
everybody he takes these kids to Europe
and stuff yeah he does I wish someone
were trying to recruit me wouldn't it be
great to come out of your house well
isn't that the way you got the cool kids
on Fox
isn't that what was first of all I want
to honor the segue that you just put
down like a disaster thank you sir thank
you sir those absolutely this is my
first old people showing I love it yeah
cuz they give us breaks like every 20
minutes once you put the makeup on
they're like is there anything get you
you know David David mist oh good get
him a chair you know and they're like
very salutis solicitous so I love it
mm-hmm yeah and so you know you and
Vicki Lawrence and Leslie Jordan and
Martin mall and you are the you are the
youngest cast member I am
chronologically okay
I know that Leslie Jordan who I love
dearly is claiming 63 mm-hmm
we haven't done the deep research but
this is what he is acknowledging yes and
then there's me I'm 62 and in Martin 75
and Vicki's unknown she could be 15
[Laughter]
right I can't and and it's part of the
aging process for you Detroit Lions
football David has that been part of the
aging process for you not last Sunday
man first of all I hate Tom Brady I hate
him with a passion but he's a mission I
don't care I don't care he's handsome he
left one of the most beautiful women in
the universe for the most beautiful
woman
he has like 800 Super Bowl rings what
does he pray for just you god it's me
Tom I just wanted to say hi I mean okay
outs maybe I'll see you tomorrow I don't
know I'm just I want to say I'm a little
depressed for being too happy
maybe all right Oh Brady checking out
know there's what this is probably I
think gonna be a challenging season
because it looks like I don't know if
Tom Brady's gonna fall off a cliff but
the Patriots seemed to be broken as an
organization what do you guys think well
every time you think they're out they
pull themselves back in okay so in their
history how many seasons have they
started like this just well one and two
it's been I don't know off the top of my
head but we have seen September
struggles before David I don't mean to
get your hopes up well what do you think
do you think they're gonna win the Super
Bowl I think they're going to the Super
Bowl this year well I hope if they go I
hope that Tom Brady yeah I hope it's a
double overtime game and the Patriots
are poised all they have to do is
advance the ball less than a yard and I
hope as the time the clock runs down he
is thwarted and they lose by one half a
point that's what I hope for so you
really don't like tie I don't I don't
like them or the pay he's got too much
good luck can he get some adversity
he's a Michigan guy I don't care he and
don't give me that I was taking what was
at the sixth round or something no one
liked me they like you now and for the
past 35 years come on please but the
Lions actually did they get your hopes
up a little bit I mean like I'm a very
fair weather football guy
basketball is really my passion so I
could tell you more about that okay you
don't really know and and the Lions have
there's my main problem with the Lions
is the color it's like steel gray
Honolulu blue is the efficient and it's
Detroit which is so Midwestern they
should be like the Detroit meatloaf
you know the Detroit bad backs it's not
the Lions you know the color scheme they
don't maybe that's been their problem I
think you know I mean you forward that
idea if you guys are out there this is
my hometown I will do a david alan grier
makeover of the Lions if you're for free
I would love that I will attack the
colors so the Pistons your team man yeah
see that's what I'm saying as we like
the Detroit gears the Detroit
automotives you know it's got to be
proud of our history like the Green Bay
Packers when I was a kid the Green Bay
Packers were our archrival
and that's what we would watch you know
but now it's gone soft you know you
can't hit fantastic I've we normally do
this when we have a celebrity guest in
so I hope you will do it as well no it's
called celebrity true or false items
from your your bio on only on the
internet celebrity true or false right
now false you were a voice actor for the
NPR adaptation of Star Wars Episode four
a new hope in 1980 yes I was
I am I my acting teacher John Madden who
directed Shakespearean love okay so not
the Oakland Raiders coach okay no
unfortunately what it what a combo that
was down to the top three-point position
no none of that
right John Madden was my acting teacher
I was in acting school he said you know
David you know I'm directing this thing
if you happen to be in LA I'll hire you
and so I did about four days and I
didn't know I thought this is Radio they
wouldn't just be radio people but Mark
Hamill was there and who was a guy that
played not r2d2 what's the talk c-3po
yeah see through Anthony what doesn't I
don't know some Anthony Daniels I might
yeah I was gonna say Andrews Daniels he
was in it it was just amazing and fun so
when out what did you play I mean did
you excuse me I played random
stormtrooper but I got $800 man and then
I was still in school I was like I'm
rich and [ __ ] out with Mark Hamill at
his house in Malibu it was awesome
fantastic and fellow Wolverine James
Earl Jones was not part of this this is
not okay well let me I forget it was so
long ago that's nice yeah he was not are
you here's the next one trained in
Shakespeare at Yale and a master of fine
arts from Yale School of Drama
absolutely true fact yes okay I did a
play with James Earl Jones it's called
Timon of Athens
Reggie Kathy who is nasty arrested he
and I were yeah college roommates and so
we were hungry desperate actors and we
played thieves and we came onto the
scene and in that production you know
James Earl Jones was having a hard time
learning his lines
so my Reggie and I we knew every line we
knew every line he was going to say and
he looked he took one look at us and he
realized I cannot drop a line in the
scene because we were looking at him
like a piece of raw meat we were like
dude I will take this monologue all the
way to the bar so he never dropped a
line every other scene okay because we
were like don't drop a line yeah yeah
now this is an interesting one David
Alan Grier according to one of your BIOS
you like hanging out in Asian
supermarkets is that us is it I do I
didn't know where that was going
right they have different cuisine man
different cuts of meat like they do if
you're into Korean barbecue boneless
short rib highly marbled like pencil
thin cuts different vegetables you know
I grew up on a MP in Detroit seriously
can peas iceberg lettuce that was maybe
some asparagus so every year if you want
to finally cut bamboo shoot' yes my
ex-wife is Korean she left but the
cuisine stay thank you honey but in last
one your first big break was a Broadway
production of the first where you played
Jackie Robinson I did that's this is all
true yeah you know so again I'm not a
big baseball guy was 1981 and as part of
the research Rachel Robinson the kids
they came and they said you should come
and see Jackie Robinson ease mm-hmm
scrapbooks and I was like you know I was
like 23 24 I was like I think I know
enough yeah I don't I finally looked at
these scrapbooks these scrapbooks were
about this big and they started all the
way from when he was a kid you know he's
a high school he lettered in every every
sport everything like I'm the mom he
could have been anything right so I did
not know the breadth of his athletic
prowess until going all the way back and
I think it was Pasadena California he
could have he was a UCLA running back oh
they had all of this I know it's on baby
brother Mac came in silver behind Jesse
Owens at the Olympics that I didn't know
33 yeah cuz I mean it games yes so so it
was amazing and mind-blowing and I got
to meet so many great baseball players
Leo Durocher came to the opening night
Ralph Branca sure and correct me if I'm
wrong and who else was it was it Bobby
Thompson who hit the game right I don't
know if he came that night but
I remember Leo Durocher Ralph Branca and
somebody else but they were all there
you know and you know all the old white
guys they were very nice I was like wow
these guys are so nice you know ready to
loose no more either nice now no they're
nice now okay I was like okay wow this
is so much fun david alan grier cool
kids a series premiere tonight on Fox at
8:30 p.m. Eastern Time please come back
and and go blue I would live what can I
say one more thing please about Tiger
Woods you know sure I have to tell you I
do not watch golf I watch Tiger Woods
okay I really don't I mean if it's not
there I just don't ask me why I'm not
really into it you know and um to watch
this thing I know that it wasn't a major
like everybody else I thought well maybe
this is it I mean he's still gonna if
you don't do anything ever and he lost
this week and he's still gonna go down
in history as one of the greatest
golfers of all time all right uh I don't
think this is the end I think he can win
another major I don't know if he's ever
gonna break Nicholas's record I just
know that I think it was Jack Nicklaus
that who said at one time he said you
know he's Tiger Woods has lost his I
forget what his term is his mojo you
know as a golfer when you were in the
zone you were in the zone but when you
are not in that zone you are not and
he's we never thought he was gonna come
back it's amazing it really was awesome
to see to this weekend it's unbelievable
so let's do have some more I agree with
you I agree with you david alan grier I
agree and I there's a great quote from
Jack Nicklaus who I love with the
exception that he went to Ohio State
that's the only thing well you know what
yeah that's right how dare you quote him
I'm not even gonna say anything you
asked me not to use profanity and it's
very hard at this point david alan grier
on twitter check out iguana baby the
cool kids on Fox 8:30 p.m. Eastern
tonight the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience